but that's equivalent to just
summing over all the strings.
So we do obtain an expression that's equivalent to the
one that we started with,
and now we can compute the
Euclidean norm squared.
It's just the sum of the squares of the absolute values
of the coefficients, and so, we get this expression right here
for our probabilities.
Of course, give yourself
time to verify this, if you choose to do that, it takes time to get used to all this
and to be able to perform
these calculations, and the more practice you give yourself, the easier it'll become.
So far, we haven't actually
made use of the promise in Simon's problem at all.
Our analysis of these probabilities actually works for any function f, but now it's time to think about Simon's
problems specifically.
We're going to break things down into the same two cases
that we had before.
The first case is that s
is the all-zero string, and the second case is that
s is not the all-zero string.
In the first case, that
s is the all-zero string, things are pretty simple.
In this case, as we saw before, we have that f is a one to one function, so there's a single string x
that gets mapped to each of the
strings z in the range of f.
That makes the absolute value squared of the sum over those strings equal to 1 because there's just a
single term in the sum,
it's either plus 1 or minus 1, but it doesn't matter which because we take the
absolute value squared, and so we get one.
There are 2 to the n
elements in the range of f, and we know that because f is one to one, so there's one string in the
range for each input string.
And if we evaluate the entire expression, we find that each string y appears with probability
one over two to the n.
So in other words, the
measurements give us a string y chosen uniformly at random.
That might not seem all that useful, but we will, in fact, be able
to distinguish this behavior from the behavior we get in the case
that s is not the all-zero string, and we'll see how that goes shortly.
For now though, we simply observe that if
f satisfies the promise in Simon's problem in the case that s is the all-zero string,
then the result of the measurements is a uniform random string.
Now let's move on to the second case, which is that the promise
is satisfied for a string s that's not the all zero-string.
In this case, as we discussed before, each string z in the range of f has exactly two strings that map to it,
because every string has a partner, and each pair of partners
maps to some unique string, and specifically, each string's partner
is the string we get by XORing with s.
So if we pick any string
z in the range of f, and we give the name w to either one of the
strings that f maps to z,
then the XOR of w with s is the
other string that maps to z.
Looking at just the one term in our sum that corresponds to whatever string z in the range that we have in mind,
we see that we can
write it more explicitly as we have right here.
We have two strings in the pre-image of z, w and w XORed with s.
So we can write the sum
as you see on the screen, and now what we can do is we can pull out a factor of
negative 1 to the power w.y.
That factor is going to be
either plus 1 or minus 1, so it goes away when we
take the absolute value,
and what we're left with is
this expression right here.
The details aren't all shown here, and it's not necessarily
obvious that it works this way, but you can check that these
two expressions are equal
by going back to the definition
of the binary dot product and thinking about what happens when these things are in
the exponent of negative 1,
not unlike what we had for the
Bernstein-Vazirani problem.
Finally, we can break this
expression up into two cases.
It's 4 when the binary dot
product of s and y is 0, and it's 0 when the binary
dot product of s and y is 1.
Notice in particular that
there's no dependence at all here on w or z, it only depends on s and y.
The reason this happens is
because of the very specific and special nature of the promise.
In essence, this is why the promise was formulated in this way, so it would all work out like this.
Again, every string has a partner, which we get by XORing with
this one hidden string s,
and that's what makes this all happen.
We can now go back to the
expression for the probabilities and plug things in.
When s is not the all-zero string, there are 2 to the n minus 1
elements in the range of f,
which is half of the
number of input strings, and plugging in the
values we just calculated gives this formula right here.
So this time, y is not a
completely random string, but rather y is uniform over exactly half of the n bit strings,